totalement terrifiant et effrayant
l'éclair et le phénomène naturel le plus
mortel et le moins résolu sur terre au
commencement de l'humanité il
représentait la colère de dieu
il frappe et de terreur notre
imagination et changer la vie de ce
qu'ils avaient subi
les éclairs frappent sans discrimination
et sans prévenir une centaine de fois
par an des hommes au hasard en sont les
victimes
certains tentent le diable en
chevauchant une chaîne de montagne
élevées ou en prenant des photos dans un
endroit désert mais les autres
deviennent des victimes dans leur train
train quotidien comme se rendre à la
poste ou préparer un repas quand l'orage
arrive il est préférable de se mettre à
l'abri
seulement parfois il est impossible de
s'abriter en eux c'est comment ni
pourquoi les clercs fera pas un endroit
pourtant couvert
cela reste inexpliqué
la grande escalade dans la chaîne de
montagne dans la sierra nevada s'appelle
le mont whitney un des points culminants
des états unis tous les ans des milliers
de randonneurs se rendent à l'est de la
californie pour gravir ces 4418 mètres
d'altitude
[Musique]
le matin du samedi 14 juillet 1990
michael wilson et son beau-frère terina
bourse se préparait à franchir le sommet
du mont whitney il avait décidé de
grimper jusqu'en haut dans la journée et
d'effectuer une boucle afin de regagner
le refuge
juste avant la tombée de la nuit le
bulletin météo de la station des gardes
forestiers de in you annoncé qu'il y
avait un léger risque d'après midi
orageux comme souvent en été tandis que
michael et terry atteignez les 3300 m
les sentiers boisés cédé la place à un
chemin difficile de pierre et les
rocailles et l'air se raréfier mike
était sans conteste en meilleure forme
que moi et dans les passages difficiles
je m'appuyais sur lui mais nous devions
maintenir notre allure jusque ce mais
sinon nous aurions dû rebrousser chemin
au croisement d'un chemin à leur tour
ils arrivaient alcool ou ce qu'ils
virent à l'est et à l'ouest
leur parut consternant nous avons
observé que le ciel était recouvert de
nuages certains d'entre eux annoncé la
pluie mais la plupart étaient assez loin
mais ce que michael terry ne pouvait
voir c'était cinéma orageux menaçant de
l'autre côté de la montagne
ils ont donc poursuivi leur marche
bientôt au détour d'un chemin de pierres
l'asim fut en vue atteindre le sommet
s'avérer maintenant chose facile encore
150 m à monter mais le temps changer
rapidement
ça s'est passé tellement vite un peu
comme si le nuage nous était brusquement
tombé dessus il était à peine cinq
heures du soir la température chute est
très vite
la pluie et la grêle se sont abattus sur
les pires nu les randonneurs cherchaient
un abri pendant dix bonnes minutes
nous avons regardé partout recherchant
le moindre recoin pour nous abriter
mais à cette altitude cela ne court pas
les rues
il y à bien les éboulis des morceaux de
roches éparpillés de tous les côtés mais
rien d'assez grand pour s'abriter et se
protéger à cet automne un éclair fera
pas un mot sur le granit
le seul abri que michael a pu trouver
était une légère saillie au milieu des
rochers
nous étions pratiquement entièrement
exposés imaginez-vous cherchant un abri
dans un parking ressemble à un désert
alors que nous avons trouvé ce petit
coin de rochers cela nous a semblé le
paradis un véritable feu d'artifice des
clercs strié le ciel sombre terry et
michael sous-équipés pourra-t-elle temps
étaient trempés jusqu'aux os pour se
protéger de cette pluie glacée terry
sorti une couverture de survie de son
sac à dos ils prirent chacun à quoi de
la couverture pour la maintenir devant
le surplomb rocheux
on avait un peu plus chaud et nous
étions assis depuis à peine 30 secondes
que cette idée m'a traversé l'esprit
cette couverture était fabriquée avec
une sorte de matériaux métalliques
la seule chose dont je me souvienne
était la phrase de michael me demandant
la notice de la couverture pour voir si
elle était contre-indiqué par temps
d'orage
c'est juste à ce moment que l'éclair a
frappé réduisant la couverture en
miettes et plat quand les deux hommes
contre les rochers
je me souviens avoir pensé
est ce la fin du monde qu'est ce qui se
passe tout autour et puis j'ai réalisé
que je ne rêvais pas petit à petit j'ai
retrouvé mes sens et je me suis entendu
pleurer et j'ai entendu pleurer terry
terry était à langer il tremblait saisie
de convulsions comme dans une sorte de
crise
alors j'ai compris ce qui s'était passé
nous avions été électrocuté j'ai regardé
le sol et j'ai vu que mes jambes
tremblaient elle aussi michael avait
l'impression que son corps se consume et
sous une chaleur terrible
il a rapproché ses jambes de son buste
est tenté de rouler hors des rochers
pour découvrir d'où venait ce feu
pas de flammes mais sa peau avait pris
une couleur brillante et pourpre et il y
avait visiblement les mains et les
doigts brûlés j'ai regardé sous le
rocher
terry était là il était secoué de
spasmes et de tremblements et un sont
épouvantables sortait de sa bouche comme
le cri primaire
michael a traîné tiré hors du rocher et
lui a mis une paire de lunettes de
soleil dans la bouche pour éviter qu'il
ne s'étouffe avec sa langue
j'ai pensé que c'était le plus gros
problème jusqu'à ce que brusquement tout
s'arrête
le bruit a cessé tout mouvement avait
stoppé il était juste et ries avait
cessé de respirer
michael pratique à la respiration
artificielle sur le corps inanimé de son
beau frère
il m'a bien fallu quinze minutes avant
que je réalise qu'il ne revenait pas à
lui pendant ce temps les éclairs n'avait
pas diminué
il continuait de craquer tout autour de
moi et parfois je ressentais les
fourmillements de la décharge électrique
qui s'enfonçait dans le sol michael a
essayé d'envoyer de l'air dans les
poumons de terry quelques minutes plus
tard terry ouvrit les yeux j'ai dit
terry nous avons été frappés par la
foudre
nous devons dégager d'ici et sa réponse
immédiate fut que s'est il passé
j'ai répété terry nous avons été frappés
par la foudre
terry avait une vertèbre cassée des
brûlures sur le visage les mains et les
chevilles
michael l'a aidé à se remettre sur pied
et a soutenu son corps affaibli il
confronte heures leurs opinions pour
savoir s'il cherchait un autre abri ou
s'il remet rousset chemin était juste
une question de temps avant que la
foudre ne frappe de nouveau j'ai vu là
zébrures d'un éclair devant nous la
décharge nous passait le long des jambes
et c'est ce qui a dû se produire
je pense qu'au moment où mike a pris la
décision il avait de loin la charge de
l'expédition il a jugé que nous devions
redescendre ils ont entamé leur descente
aussi rapidement que possible
épuisé et grelottant il dévalait les
pierres enneigées et prirent des
raccourcis difficile à travers les
sentiers je parlais sans ménagement
atterri pour le faire avancer
je lui disais terry veux-tu encore
revoir ta femme et tes enfants
je pensais vraiment que si j'avais pu me
reposer un instant j'irai mieux et s'il
n'avait tenu qu'à moi je serais resté et
nous ne serions jamais revenu de la
montagne ayant survécu à deux éclairs
fulgurant terry et michael craignirent
ensuite de mourir d'hypothermie
finalement après quatre heures de lutte
ils trouvèrent un camping les campeurs
en roulèr les randonneurs gelés dans des
sacs de couchage et leur donnèrent de la
soupe chaude
la nouvelle de randonneurs accidentés
avaient été diffusés sur les radios les
autorités du comté de ligne au une
équipe de secours se diriger vers la
montagne et vers minuit ils atteignirent
michael et terry ils nous ont ausculté
afin de voir s'il n'y avait aucune
fractures et brûlures sérieuses et si
nous étions suffisamment d'aplomb pour
passer la nuit au camping
finalement nous avons pu rester la nuit
sous la tente
le lendemain matin terry a été
aéroportée à l'hôpital michael a choisi
de rentrer seul je repensais à cette
randonnée
on était près du sommet et on a dû faire
demi-tour dans des conditions atroces
je sentais que j'avais vraiment besoin
d'évacuer toutes ces tensions par ma
propre volonté
même si la plupart d'entre nous sommes
conscients de notre vulnérabilité au
beau milieu d'un orage et des éclairs
impressionnant nous ne réalisons pas
combien les scientifiques ont encore
beaucoup à apprendre au sujet des ses
éclairs mortels on ne comprend pas
exactement comment ils frappent la terre
on ne comprend pas non plus comment
cette connexion se fait quand il frappe
et pourquoi pas plus que nous savons
quand il démarre d'un nuage martin human
est l'un des chercheurs les plus
renommés au monde sur les éclairs
pendant 25 ans il a essayé de comprendre
ces détails mystérieux autour d'eux les
chercheurs croient que les éclairs sur
une réaction électrique a porté par des
déséquilibres de courant dans les nuages
orageux l'éclair est une version
amplifiée de la petite décharge
électrique que vous ressentez quand vous
vous êtes frotter à une couverture et
que vous touchez une poignée de porte
c'est une décharge de quelques
millimètres l'éclair mur 16,80 parfois
100 km de long chaque année de plus en
plus de randonneurs sont confrontés à
cette force impressionnante de la nature
trop tard souvent pour s'abriter ils
sont blessés ou tués
pourquoi sur une aussi vulnérable les
gens sont frappés par les clercs soit
parce qu'ils sont sûrs un point
culminant ou soit parce qu'ils sont
connectés à l'objet le plus élevé autour
d'eux en étant les plus hauts dans un
champ ou sommet d'une montagne
il offre une connexion possible avec le
sol la personne se tient debout
le circuit est complet à haute altitude
trouver un abri dans les montagnes est
presque impossible
michael et terry pensez être protégé par
un piton rocheux
mais l'éclair peut frapper et faire mal
même indirectement
quand il frappe dans les montagnes une
personne peut essayer de se cacher
derrière des pierres mais quand il pleut
à torrent et que les éclairs déchirent
le ciel tout autour du rocher le courant
traverse l'eau puis est conduit par elle
dans les moindre trou de ce rocher ou
n'avaient ainsi pas beaucoup de
protection déterminé à finir la
randonnée qu'ils avaient commencé
michael et son beau-frère terry retourne
au mont whitney et partent à l'ascension
du sommet le temps éclair le ciel dégagé
mais ils se souviennent des éléments
déchaînés quand vous faites l'ascension
d'un sommet il existe certes un risque
non calculé mais vous tentez votre
chance vous savez que vous n'avez aucun
contrôle sur la nature il faut seulement
l'accepter je me sentais comme la
première fois il ya fort longtemps
j'étais vraiment arriver à apprécier le
temps qui m'étaient offertes sur la
terre et en profiter au maximum
vous ne savez jamais quand votre fin
arrivera
l'électrocution elle-même dure une
fraction de seconde mais les dégâts
occasionnés dure toute la vie
[Musique]
un nombre impressionnant de gens
survivent à une électrocution
s'ils ne reçoivent pas la décharge
maximale sans en être totalement sûr des
scientifiques pensent que la décharge
passe le long du corps et non à travers
lui
mais qu'est-ce qui peut endommager le
système nerveux et changer les fonctions
cérébrales et ainsi que le découvert une
californienne
il n'existe aucun remède par un froid
matin de septembre 1991
jason quitta sa maison de san jose en
californie pour se rendre à son travail
de gros nuages noirs à commencer
assombrir le ciel matinal au travail
joyce se prépare une tasse de thé puis
ayant mis ses écouteurs elle s'installe
à son bureau
ton pied droit posé sur un petit
radiateur électrique métallique joyce
regarde la pluie frappé les carreaux ses
collègues se plaignait de ce temps un
couvent table alors que joyce était
fasciné mais alors que la tempête
semblait s'atténuer
elle s'est sentie mal à l'aise
l'éclair a été si intense que vous
pouviez l'entendre crépiter comme s'ils
se trouvaient dans le bureau et le
tonnerre a secoué tout le bâtiment
brusquement un éclair a illuminé le ciel
tandis que le tonnerre a grondé en même
temps le bâtiment avait été touché la
décharge électrique de l'éclair
voyageant à travers les lignes
téléphoniques a atterri dans les
écouteurs de joyce le courant a tiré par
le petit radiateur électrique métallique
lui a aussi traversé le pire
immédiatement joyce a ressenti de la
douleur et s'est senti mal j'ai pensé
que j'avais une crise cardiaque
j'ai commencé à ressentir une vive
douleur dans le bus et le bras droit
consciente que quelque chose n'allait
vraiment pas joyce a voulu en parler à
sa patronne
mais elle était incapable de sortir un
mot cohérent plus tard elle m'a dit
avoir eu l'impression que je parlais
chinois elle ne comprenait rien de ce
que je lui racontais son état empirant
son bureau à plat une ambulance
en voulant me lever pour me rendre à
l'hôpital
je me suis rendu compte que je ne
pouvais plus tendres ma jambe droite
parce qu'à chaque fois que j'essayais de
la redresser
c'était comme si l'on enfoncé un
poignard dans le coeur
brusquement alors qu'elles étaient
transportés par l'équipe médicale
sa douleur a disparu elle fut envahie
par une sensation de chaleur et de
bien-être
[Musique]
c'était comme une lumière éclatante
j'avais l'impression d'être dans un
nuage
c'était chaud et radieux et je me suis
sentie totalement en paix cette étrange
sensation de calme fut brève
à l'hôpital les médecins ne trouvèrent
pas la cause de cette douleur intense
beaucoup d'entre eux ne prennent pas
trop au sérieux les plaines des gens
électrocutés
parce que les dégâts internes de
l'électrocution ne se voit ni dans les
examens standard ni à la radio les
spécialistes eux pensent que les
dommages ne peuvent être vus car il se
situe au niveau cellulaire notre corps
entier travaillent par impulsions
électriques soient vos nerfs ou les
muscles ou votre rythme cardiaque tout
est électrique
il n'est donc pas déraisonnable de
penser que même si vous transmettez de
minuscules charge électrique à travers
votre corps vous ne pouvez provoquer des
changements réversible ou irréversibles
dans les enzymes et les mécanismes
cellulaires les séquelles nerveuse ne
peuvent être signalés au cerveau que par
la douleur
l'irritation ou un comportement
inhabituel de la personne il ne restait
pas une seule partie de mon corps qui
n'avaient pas été touchés j'avais mal
partout aux yeux et je ne pouvais plus
me coiffer car même mes cheveux me
faisait souffrir marché était devenu
impossible je rampais je ne pouvais plus
marcher
après deux jours d'hospitalisation joyce
est rentrée chez elle sa douleur et sa
souffrance reste inexpliqué
au fil du temps à ces maux physiques
joyce doute ajouter des changements dans
son comportement alimentaire une soif
constante puis un assèchement de la peau
de la somme ni et une perte de cheveux
[Musique]
la température de mon corps changer tout
le temps je ne pouvais dormir sans
ventilateur et parfois mon corps était
si brûlant que j'avais l'impression
d'être chauffé à blanc mais actuellement
particulièrement du côté droit
j'ai des problèmes ne se je les sens
comme des glaçons cela fait mal vraiment
trop mal et il n'y a rien à faire pour
me soulager mentalement joyce se bat
avec d'autres symptômes l'affaiblissant
comme la perte de mémoire et des
changements dans sa personnalité
avant je faisais partie de la chorale de
ma paroisse j'enseignais le langage des
signes et je faisais le catéchisme
maintenant j'ai tout oublié
je ne me souviens ni des signes ni des
versets de la bible ni d'aucune chansons
j'aimais la compagnie je me sentais plus
sereine au milieu des gens que tout seul
maintenant pour être apaisées joyce
passe le plus clair de son temps dans
son jardin à s'occuper de ses fleurs et
des légumes que la négligence d'un
voisin abîmé son jardin joyce a été pris
d'une monstrueuse colère une autre c'est
qu'elle sonnait l'hydrocution je pensais
alors que la seule chose qui pourrait me
calmer serait de le tuer
je suis resté dans cet état pendant
trois jours je ne dormais plus j'ai
pleuré trois jours j'étais totalement
déprimé par cette situation qui n'était
que broutilles et pendant tout ce temps
je ne rêvais que d'une chose comment tu
es mon voisin le plus proche
finalement la colère de joyce est
retombé l'aller sont effrayés par ce
qu'était devenu son fonctionnement de
penser après je me rendais compte que
c'était fou mais durant ce laps de temps
rien ne me semblait logique
ma raison n'existait plus et cela est
extrêmement dur pour moi
vous comprenez
on ne sait pas très bien pourquoi
certaines personnes survivent à une
électrocution
même si la radioactivité de l'éclair est
six fois plus importante que celle du
soleil beaucoup d'énergie se dissipe
dans l'air avant d'atteindre le sol
peu de choses sont connues des séquelles
à long terme sur le corps humain
le docteur mary cooper est l'un des
chercheurs de l'université d'illinois
chicago spécialiste des effets médicaux
de ces électrocution elle a enregistré
les dommages causés par les éclairs sur
l'homme depuis 20 ans la chose la plus
difficile pour les victimes est de ne
pas être crues si vous êtes touché par
un éclair la plupart du temps vous serez
observé sur l'extérieur de votre corps
et non à l'intérieur
et pourtant vous n'êtes plus le même
votre charge électrique ne fonctionnent
plus correctement et votre cerveau à
changer de directives un autre chercheur
margrethe primeau et neuropsychologues à
l'école de médecine de chicago elle
affirme que le système nerveux et les
vaisseaux sanguins sont particulièrement
vulnérables à l'électricité parce
qu'étant liquide
il offre un passage facile pour le
courant nous savons aussi que le courant
entre dans la tête par les orifices tels
que les yeux les oreilles le nez et la
bouche etc y at-il entre vos yeux et vos
oreilles
votre cerveau aussi s évident que le
courant traverse le cerveau même si la
personne ne semble pas relié à quoi que
ce soit par sa tête
utilisant une technique nouvelle est
controversée lectra encéphalogramme
quantitatif qe2 j'ai le cerveau de josh
et analyser les résultats ont été
décryptés par le neurologue fernando
miranda dans le cas de joyce les parties
du cerveau ne fonctionnant pas
correctement son frontale ainsi que son
côté droit
cela pourrait affecter son jugement en
lui influents des pulsions incontrôlées
et une mauvaise orientation de sa
mémoire spatiale
margaret primo pense que ce type de
dégâts du cerveau pourrait expliquer la
colère subite de joyce c'est une perte
apparente de la personnalité je ne pense
pas que ce soit un nouveau trait de
personnalité n'ayant jamais existé chez
elle elle devait l'avoir en elle mais
auparavant elle le maîtrisait et le
contrôler
pour joyce qui ne se souvient même plus
de son âge ni qu autrefois lmh et les
éclairs une guérison complète lui semble
utopique
les nombreux médicaments prescrits au
fil des ans lui ont offert des
soulagement mais pas le vrai remède le
système nerveux central ne guérit pas
celui en périphérie se détériore encore
quant à la moelle épinière aucun
changement
ainsi puisqu'il semble y avoir des
dommages permanents dans le cerveau lui
même elle ne guérira pas avec l'avancée
de la recherche
le docteur cooper pense qu'un jour de
nouveaux médicaments pourront apporter
la guérison aux dommages neurologiques
du cerveau subie par les victimes de
l'électrocution
mais pour l'instant la guérison dépend
des amis des médecins et de sa volonté à
survivre longtemps j'ai regretté de ne
pas avoir été tués
je voulais mourir mais maintenant j'ai
fait le point et cela va mieux pour moi
les choses sont normales
en moyenne chaque seconde des centaines
d' éclairs frappent quelque part dans le
monde
les chances d'être électrocuté par l'un
d'eux sont de 1 sur 500 1000
incroyablement une femme l'a été non pas
une fois mais trois fois à une heure de
l'après-midi le 15 septembre 1983
linda cooper finissait son travail le
temps à force myers avait été orageux
toute la matinée mais juste au moment où
elle s'apprêtait à effectuer quelques
courses le ciel menacé de virer à
l'orage et à la pluie la floride est une
région à tempête
tout le monde le sait mais on n'en tient
pas compte je devais me rendre à la
banque et à la poste aussi j'ai pris le
risque et j'y suis allé linde a quitté
la banque et se rendit à la poste elle
s'arrêta sur le bord du trottoir juste
devant l'entrée
j'avais juste un petit collier et
quelques lettres a posté besoin
d'acheter des timbres une banale course
à la poche alors que je marchais
m'apprêtais à franchir la porte
l'éclair a frappé j'ai cru qu'une
grenade avait explosé à mes côtés la
lumière était la plus éblouissante
lumière que j'ai vu et le bruit
assourdissant un éclair avait frappé le
mar devant le bureau de poste est
ensuite linda elle avait été projetée
sur le sol
[Musique]
je crois qu'il a traversé le mât et m'a
frappé sur la tête parce que j'ai un
endroit sûr celle ci qui semble plus
fragile il y a une légère coupure qui
montre que c'est par là que le courant
est entré dans mon corps depuis ce jour
linda est soumise aux mêmes symptômes
dont souffrent les autres victimes
fatigue chronique douleur pertes de
mémoire et maux de tête persistants
malgré ces dommages et sa peur linda est
heureuse malgré tout d'être encore en
vie
cet accident a changé ma vie et je sais
que c'est définitif
j'ai perdu beaucoup de temps avec ma
fille adolescente
je dormais alors que j'aurais pu faire
tant de choses avec elle cela a
bouleversé ma version antérieure des
choses et me fait apprécié chaque
instant de la vie comme un cadeau
linda a passé les dix années suivantes à
reconstruire sa vie en partie détruite
par la foudre et dans la crème des
orages je faisais très attention aux
éclairs je ne téléphonait pas je ne
faisais pas la vaisselle ni la lessive
en pha riad ce qui n'était pas
recommandé d'effectuer par temps d'orage
en mai 1993 linda discuté au téléphone
avec sa fille
lorsqu'un orage digne de la floride
éclata d'un seul coup un courant
électrique passe par le téléphone me
frappe sur le côté de la tête ébranle
notre maison j'ai hurlé lâché le
téléphone mon mari est arrivé en courant
frappé pour la seconde fois
linda est effrayé plus qu'elle n'a été
blessé j'ai ressenti les mêmes
fourmillements que lorsque vos nerfs
bouge tout seul et je restais là en état
de choc en me disant non mon dieu s'il
vous plaît aux noms pourquoi cette fois
ci la douleur et la fatigue n'ont duré
que quelques mois
l'année suivante linda sa famille
voyager en caroline du sud où les orages
ne sont pas réputés violents quand
l'orage a éclaté le 11 juillet 1994
l'expérience avait appris à linda ce
qu'il fallait faire ou ne pas faire
je ne devais pas faire la lessive me
servir du moindre ustensiles électrique
le dîner cuisait dans un récipient et
linda est assise à la table de la
cuisine en train de travailler quand
elle décida de préparer un dessert ma
famille aime les desserts il adore la
gelée aussi je prépare cet entremets le
place dans le réfrigérateur puis j'ai
voulu laver le récipient je me suis
dirigé vers les vielles et lorsque j'ai
tourné le robinet l'éclair a craqué puis
le courant est passé le long de mon bras
cette fois ci je l' ai senti mon bras
était en feu
je suis allé vers le réfrigérateur j'ai
ouvert le congélateur et j'ai mis le
haut de mon corps et mon bras dedans et
je suis resté là essayant de me calmer
linda est restée assise frigorifié
puisqu'elle que son mari l'a trouve deux
heures et demie plus tard je l' ai juste
regarder et me suis mise à pleurer
chéri lui ai-je dit elle ment encore
frappé il m'a pris ma serre et en me
demandant mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
subissant encore une fois traumatisme et
nausées linda est resté avec beaucoup de
questions sans réponse notamment une
pourquoi pourquoi certaines personnes
attire-t-elle la foudre
quelqu'un qui ait frappé plusieurs fois
par la foudre et seulement victime du
hasard car rien dans l'individu ne
laisse voir quelque chose de spécial il
n'y a rien de commun entre six victimes
hormis qu'elles sont peut-être plus
souvent dehors que les autres qu'elles
étaient électrocutés plusieurs fois ou
juste une fois
les victimes sont souvent réticentes à
parler de leur expérience
elles se sentent embarrassé et sont
fatigués de ne pas être crues une
association appelée victime
d'international de la foudre des
courants électriques a été créée en 1987
pour aider les survivants raconter leur
histoire
j'ai été électrocuté trois fois la
première fois je vivais en floride
c'était en 1983
à ce moment là je ne connaissais
personne qui avait été frappé par la
foudre mais maintenant j'en côtoie je
m'aperçois que nous ressentons tous les
mêmes symptômes
il arrive aussi que la foudre frappe
lors des sports de loisirs en plein air
beaucoup de golfeurs entre autres sur
électrocuté lors des compétitions
annuelles
un homme se trouvait dans son allée
nettoyant les vitres de sa camionnette
lorsque la foudre l'a touché la foudre
est arrivé et a frappé ma camionnette
comme je faisais conducteur avec mon
véhicule à cause de l'eau elle est
descendu le long de mon côté gauche
ce qu'il faut retenir des paroles de
survivants c'est leur expérience et
surtout écouter et apprendre de leurs
erreurs
le plus important pour moi est
d'apprendre aux gens à ne pas faire
n'importe quoi en cas d'orage ne pas
jouer au golf par temps orageux il y
aura bien d'autres jours pour jouer ne
travaillez pas dans les champs ne vous
promenez pas sur la plage sous les
éclairs soyez prudent avec la foudre car
elle est puissante et peuvent vous
blesser voire vous tuer
la fureur de la nature à alimenter
pendant des siècles les mythes
fantastique et les légendes
même si la science po d'expliquer
beaucoup des phénomènes observés dans le
ciel
beaucoup croient en cours au mystère et
à une puissance divine derrière les
éclairs un photographe amateur pense
qu'il a saisi cette présence
surnaturelle
sur un cliché comme beaucoup de
photographes qui chasse les clairs steve
malvina une relation particulière avec
les orages déchaînés alors que les
chasseurs tirent sur les animaux les
trophées des photographes ne sont qu'un
cliché un photographe attendra souvent
longtemps avant de capturer la photo
unique celle qu'ils recherchent et qu'il
exposera chez lui au fil des ans avec
sur l'appareil
steve a pris beaucoup de photos devant
sa maison de madison dans l'ohio le soir
du 12 juin 1989 était lourd et humide
un orage menacé par l'est avant ça a
progressivement par le lac érié d'yves
ayant regardé la dernière météo télévisé
annonçant la tempête se préparer pour ce
qu'il pensait être une série d' éclairs
exceptionnel j'ai pensé que je devais
installé deux appareils photo et deux
trépieds et tout poser sur les hauteurs
vue commencée à chronométrer le temps
entre les éclairs pendant que l'orage
déplacerait il a noté l'avancement de la
tempête toutes les 15 minutes à minuit
elle est apparue sur l'horizon juste
devant sa maison
il est clair que ce qu'il attendait
déchirée maintenant le ciel noir
j'avais l'impression de voir un éclair
unique qui me semble est magnifique je
me suis dit c'est peut être ma nuit
steve amish l'appareil photo en
batteries dans la bonne direction
il a ouvert l'opérateur et à regarder
les éclairs à travers la lentille
il a ensuite avancé la pellicule pour
une nouvelle photo l'éclair s'est
montrée il a pressé le déclencheur à
nouveau brusquement il s'est passé un
truc bizarre dans l'air comme une
sensation de vide le poil de mes bras se
hérissaient je savais à ce moment là que
ce n'était pas normal
steve a voulu tout ranger rentrer au
plus vite mais il ne pouvait pas bouger
c'était comme si j'étais cloué au sol
les cheveux dressés sur la tête
j'entendais des chouettes mans comme un
steak sur le grill justin et ce fut la
dernière chose que j'ai entendue
le ch vêtements a été suivie
immédiatement par une nouvelle aide à
celles blanche et lumineuse tout ce qui
se passait autour de moi étaient
incroyables inexplicables
comme si j'avais été drogué un sentiment
de calme de paix j'ai commencé à pleurer
je ne savais même pas pourquoi ce
n'était pas la peur mais pourtant
quelque chose de grave arrivait tous les
problèmes et les ennuis tout ce qui
m'était arrivé semblait s'être envolé
steve se souvient ensuite qu'il était
couché sur le dos les éclairs zébraient
le ciel autour de lui et la pluie lui
non dit le visage il a attrapé de
l'appareil photo et a foncé chez lui
la sacoche de l'appareil semblaient
fondu ça fait très peur j'avais réalisé
qu'il avait dû se passer des choses
mais j'étais encore en vie je suis
émerveillé par tout ce qui m'est arrivé
l'appareil photo abîmée a été démontée
par un technicien
le film qui n'avait pas été détruit
plutôt enlevée et développer le
développement s'est révélé un tirage
comme steve n'en avait jamais vu
auparavant
quand j'ai regardé cette pellicule pour
la première fois c'était un peu comme si
les éclairs venait des nuages
cela ressemblait à des fantômes dont on
distingue presque les corps vous pouviez
voir deux trous étaient ce les yeux une
partie d'un bras deux jambes un torse
c'est effrayant
pendant des années steve a lutté pour
trouver une explication aux émotion
qu'il avait ressentie et s comme un état
proche de la mort la photo prouve dit il
la présence d'une force spirituelle
ces photos ont capté des images que
personne ne peut expliquer un phénomène
hors du commun
le chercheur martin ou man ne sait que
penser de ces photos il y voit des
éclairs mais la façon dont steve a pris
la photo les montres à l'envers c'est
une photo d'un nuage qui forment un
éclair il ya le canal principal vers le
sol et ici le bras fourchue hélas
d'esprit mais la question est qu'est ce
que c'est et je ne connais pas la
réponse
en fait tout le monde a sa propre idée
de ce que cela pourrait être une fois
j'ai eu le point de vue d'un médium qui
m'a dit que j'avais photographié ma
propre âme est impossible de dire ce qui
s'est réellement passé
certains disent que c'est l'eau sur la
lentille ou que l'appareil photo a su
bien trop longtemps d'exposition le
métérologue et pasteur andré bernier
croit que ses opinions peuvent être
plausible
toutefois il reste toujours les
spéculations sur les mystérieux dessein
de dieu
les voies de la providence dit on sont
impénétrables j'ai examiné attentivement
la photo afin d'y chercher tout d'abord
une explication rationnelle mais que
dire de cette étrange forme humaine que
l'on distingue
il n'existe pas d'explications claires
bien sûr il serait vraiment intéressant
et plus simple de croire qu'il y avait
quelque chose déterré de spirituel saisi
par la pellicule ce côté éternité je
doute que nous le connaissions un jour
mais c'est bon de croire certaines des
expériences physiques de steve sont
similaires de celle d'autres personnes
ayant approché de près les éclairs il
décrit ses cheveux se dressent sur sa
tête comme un avertissement qu'un éclair
va frapper quand les clercs descend sur
le sol il vient à proximité de la
surface et semble regarder autour de lui
dans un rayon de 45 m
cherchant l'endroit où frappe
les arbres les pointes l'épaule puissant
les cheveux des gens qui se dresse tout
est un conducteur potentiel et lorsqu'il
me trouve
il fera pas steve a aussi expliqué que
lorsque l'éclair a frappé le sol
ils n'avaient pas entendu de coup de
tonnerre mais juste un choix tu mens une
autre indication qui prouverait qu'il
était vraiment proche du point d'impact
le tonnerre est causée par un
réchauffement extrêmement rapide de
l'air proche du noyau de l'éclair il se
propage partout sur 45 à 90 km aux
alentours
et puis les ondes se replie sur elle
même tout ceci s'effectue en un millième
de seconde est produit à la fin une
seule ondes sonores qui est le tonnerre
si vous êtes à l'intérieur de ce premier
sont tout ce que vous entendrez sera un
petit hat man un craquement ou un
crépitement ceux qui restent
inexplicables
est ce mystérieux sentiment de paix et
de calme ressentie par steve
joyce ou s'il a vécu ainsi que le
randonneur michael wilson c'était
vraiment tentant de fermer les yeux et
de me laisser porter par l'instant par
cette sensation de douce chaleur mais
j'étais persuadé que si je m'abandonnait
à cela c'est exactement ce qui se
passerait pour moi ce serait la fin
maintenant steve mais le n est plus
prudent quand ils chassent les tempêtes
avec son appareil photo
il espère qu'un jour viendra où
quelqu'un lui expliquera ce qu'il a
photographiés
[Musique]
la puissance de la foudre frappant
directement peut être fatale mais
peut-on réellement guérir d'une seule
petite décharge
[Musique]
presque tous les survivants à une
athènes de la foudre souffre de graves
problèmes médicaux quelques uns
seulement affirment être guéri
[Musique]
en juillet 1993 betty galvan au est
tombé et s'est fracturé la hanche pour
replacer l'os correctement 10 broches en
acier ont été implantés dans son fémur
droit et dans l'os iliaque
pendant un an elle s'est déplacée avec
un déambulateur plus avec une canne sa
lente guérison était un grand changement
dans sa vie
habituellement active avant j'ai
toujours été une personne très active et
subitement je me retrouve réduite à ne
pas pouvoir faire grand chose
chaque fois que je me levais pour
marcher ma jambe me sembler lourde comme
un sac de sable alors je restais là
debout à faire la grimace puis je me
disais allez je vais faire cette balade
betty fervente catholique a demandé à
ses amis de prier avec elle pour un
prompt rétablissement
j'ai toujours prié pour ma jambe parce
qu'à l'église
il m'est très pénible de m'agenouiller
le samedi 11 juin 1994
betty a assisté à la messe de l'après
midi et s'est confessé puis elle a
regagné la maison de son fils à fort
lauderdale chez qui elle séjourner aux
alentours de 5 heures du soir betty se
trouvait dans la cuisine en train de
couper les brocolis
dehors la tempête approchait la fenêtre
était ouverte mais les stores baissés
empêcher betty de voir les sombres
nuages orageux
[Musique]
ça brusquement un coup de tonnerre
terrible éclata et il m'a semblé que la
cuisine entière était éclairé cela m'a
ébranlé de partout le couteau à voler
dans les airs et les brocolis se sont
éparpillés dans la cuisine je tombe à la
renverse et immédiatement je ressens
comme des millions et des millions
d'aiguilhe qui me transperce le pied ma
jambe était tout engourdies et je ne
pouvais plus bouger mon genou le mari de
betty se précipitaient pour la prendre
dans ses bras et l'a porté sur la canapé
et lui masse à la jambe
jusqu'à ce que la sensibilité
disparaissent tandis que j'étais étendue
je regardais par la fenêtre je voyais le
jardin et une partie d'arc en ciel
c'était tellement beau que je me suis
dit que dieu me protéger je me sentais
vraiment entre les mains de dieu
et lorsqu'enfin j'ai pu me lever et me
tenir sur mes jambes
cette sensation de lourdeur dans ma
jambe avait totalement disparu
au contraire je la sentais plein d'une
toute nouvelle énergie dans sa fille est
rentrée de son travail le soir et là
tout de suite remarqué un changement
dans l'attitude de sa mère j'ai observé
une énorme différence dans sa façon de
marcher elle ne se plaignait plus
c'était tellement fou car je savais
combien elle souffrait elle aurait pu se
tuer sous la douleur bettiche suppose
que l'éclair est entré par la fenêtre
ouverte ou par les vielles jusqu'à six
pieds nus lendemain elle s'est rendue à
l'église pour raconter aux prêtres ce
qui s'était passé
[Musique]
il a émis une sorte de rire et m'a dit
que j'avais été assommée par l'esprit et
c'est bien le genre d'explications à
laquelle je crois pour cette guérison
est ce le courant électrique de l'éclair
qui a soulagé la jambe de meetic ou une
sorte de placebo une excuse pour
expliquer sa croyance dans sa guérison
presque miraculeuse médicalement d'après
les experts une éventualité de guérison
est toujours possible d'autant qu'il
reste énormément de facteurs inconnus au
sujet des éclairs
de plus les décharges électriques sont
parfois utilisées pour guérir de
dépression ou des fractures mais dans le
cas d'une guérison accidentelle les
spécialistes doutent il existe des
histoires autour de jean sourd ou
aveugle guéri par la foudre après avoir
été frappé par la foudre
cela engendre inévitablement des dégâts
au niveau du système nerveux
il se passe des connexions et des
déconnexions du système électrique et je
ne pourrais pas dire que ce genre de
miracle est impossible mais parler des
événements séparément est plus facile
que dans leur globalité
j'ai appris une chose en écoutant tous
ces gens garder l'esprit ouvert afin
d'être capable de les écouter et de
s'imaginer ce qu'ils avaient pu subir
en général la foudre a plutôt tendance à
les rendre malades plutôt que bien aussi
merci mon dieu s'il rend la guérison
possible mais je ne conseillerai jamais
à quelqu'un de se tenir sous l'orage
pour guérir tous ces mots pour en savoir
plus sur tous ses mystères entourant les
éclairs des scientifiques du monde
entier poursuivre leurs recherches dans
un laboratoire d'une université en
floride
il crée des éclairs artificielle en
envoyant des fusées dans les nuages
orageux qui se forment souvent dans
cette région il est difficile d'étudier
des éclairs karine éclate jamais quand
vos instruments sont préenregistrés des
mesures tous les avantages de ce
programme est clair sur mesure avec ces
fusées reliés à des conducteurs nous
forçons les nuages à produire un éclair
que nous conduisons où nous voulons
étudier les survivants de la foudre est
évidemment plus délicat parce que des
sujets humains ne peuvent pas être
exposés à des décharges électriques même
contrôlé pour les chercheurs c'est le
mystère qui les entourent qui leur fait
vouloir les écouter avec un jour ils
puissent comprendre pourquoi certains
survivent et d'autres pas mais chaque
cas d'électrocution est différent tout
dépend de la force en charge électrique
de l'éclair ou des vêtements portés par
les victimes ainsi que le fait qu'ils
étaient et secs ou mouillés
il n'existe vraiment aucune explication
rationnelle et je pense qu'il coulera
encore beaucoup d'encre avant que l'on
soit capable d'expliquer ces phénomènes
c'est cette mystérieuse photo qui
m'intéresse car ce n'est pas toujours la
même représentation
on a l'impression que ce sont 2 et cléa
différent et on ne sait pas pourquoi
et c'est ce côté là que je veux étudier
plus à fond
la première étude sérieuse sur les
éclairs a démarré il y a deux cents ans
quand benjamin franklin a fait voler son
fameux cerf-volant
avant les éclairs était toujours entouré
le pouvoir mythologiques
les indiens d'amérique pensais que
c'était les ailes d'un oiseau divin qui
fabriquait le tonnerre les grecs croyait
que les éclairs était la colère de zeus
quant au latin il s'en servait pour
prédire le futur soit craint soit
vénérer la foudre a toujours eu sa place
dans les esprits crédules sur la terre
entière les éclairs frappent environ une
centaine de fois à la seconde il existe
une sorte de vases communicants entre
les décharges qui monte et celle qui
descendent
quelles sont les charges exactes quel
rôle joue-t-elle sur le système
biologique en frappant la terre que se
passe-t-il au niveau du champ magnétique
de la terre nous ne savons rien
exactement même s'il semble que nous
vivions parallèle avec l'éclair
il a sans discrimination aucune
interrompu des milliers de vies soit que
vous glissiez des sommes mais à pic ou
marcher tranquillement dans votre ville
ou que vous chassiez les tempêtes
produisant ces éclairs fascinant
les conséquences sont multiples et tout
aussi tragique des traumatismes
émotionnels des dommages neurologiques
et des questions sans réponse mais un
monde sans éclair n'est pas envisageable
nous serions privés du plus
extraordinaire spectacle son et lumière
que seule la nature peut nous offrir
mais aussi de la puissance naturelle la
plus in expliqué
[Musique]
vous